I think that's entirely false. The metaverse, doesn't that date back to like Snow Crash or something from like the 70s or 80s? Whatever, my point is that we were first. Whatever, I mean, that's not a fact and my point is that I'm right. Correct. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 71, recorded on March 27th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about APL, COBOL, BASIC, and we recap the 2022 GTC Conference and Functional Conf Conference. This will be episode 71 here. We just dropped episode 70, which was the programming language quiz.
我认为那完全是错误的。元宇宙，这个概念不是可以追溯到像《雪崩》那样70年代或80年代的东西吗？不管怎样，我的意思是，我们才是最早的。不管怎样，我的意思是，那不是事实，我的观点是我才是对的。没错。欢迎收看第71期 ADSP 播客节目，录制于2022年3月27日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起讨论了 APL、COBOL、BASIC，我们还回顾了2022年 GTC 大会和 Functional Conf 大会。这就是第71期节目。我们刚发布了第70期节目，那是一期编程语言测验。
And so we're going to record two. This one will be episode 71. What we're going to talk about in this one will be a conference recap because GTC just happened all last week and lots of talks um happened and then also functional conf um just ended which was a virtual conference that took place on india standard time so i was asleep for most of it but i did stay up till like one slash two a couple
所以我们要录制两期。这一期将是第71期。我们在这一期里要聊的是会议回顾，因为 GTC 刚刚在上周全周举行，有很多精彩的演讲，然后 Functional Conf 也刚刚结束，这是一个按印度标准时间举办的虚拟会议，所以我基本上都在睡觉，不过我有几天还是熬夜到了一两点
nights and then woke up at like 6 38 this is a conference that was held in India? Well, it's held online, but it historically takes place in India. Yeah, it's like they call it the premier functional programming conference in Asia. But before we start doing our recap, conference recap, about all the exciting stuff that got announced and the talks that took place.
然后大概6点38分就醒了。这是一个在印度举办的会议吗？嗯，它是线上举办的，但历史上它总是在印度举行。对，人们称它为亚洲顶级函数式编程会议。但在我们开始回顾之前，也就是关于所有发布的新鲜事和那些精彩演讲的会议回顾……
Thesis, maybe not, but I am submitting a paper to array 2022, which is a co-located conference with PLDI. I think I mentioned that last time, but that might've not made it into episode seven. For those who do not know PLDI is like the major conference for programming language research in, in the CS academia.
论文，也许算不上，但我正在向 Array 2022 提交一篇论文，这是一个与 PLDI 联合举办的会议。我想我上次提到过，但那可能没有被收录进第七集。对于那些不知道的人来说，PLDI 是计算机科学学术界关于编程语言研究的顶级会议。
Yeah. And so it's being held in San Diego in June. And yeah, the paper is all about, it's honestly, I think it's like, it's a culmination of like two years of me deep diving into combinators and APL and other array languages. And also too, this is worth a whole episode to itself,
对。它将于6月在圣迭戈举行。是的，这篇论文全部关于……说实话，我认为这是我两年来深入研究组合子、APL 和其他数组语言的集大成之作。而且，这也是一个足够撑起整整一期节目的内容，
is that I've recently done a couple really big deep dives on two programming languages called FP and FL that are from john backus. And I actually remembered mentioning it back in I think was like episode 47 or something, the one where we were waiting for Dave Abrahams and you made me explain combinatory logic and combinators to you. So there's an episode called Combinatory Logic. And in that episode, I actually referred to this language FP and John Backus introduced it. I want to clarify that we're talking about John Backus, the computer scientist with a CK, not John Backus, the football player with a CH. But yes, this is the John Backus behind Algol Fortran, and that won the Turing Award in 1977.
那就是我最近对两种名为 FP 和 FL 的编程语言进行了几次非常深入的研究，它们是约翰·巴克斯（John Backus）的作品。我其实记得在大概第47期还是什么的节目里提到过它，就是我们等戴夫·阿布拉姆斯（Dave Abrahams）的那期，你让我给你解释组合逻辑和组合子。所以有一期节目叫《组合逻辑》。在那期节目中，我确实提到了 FP 语言，这是约翰·巴克斯引入的。我想澄清一下，我们讨论的是计算机科学家约翰·巴克斯，名字拼写带 ck，而不是那个名字拼写带 ch 的足球运动员约翰·巴克斯。不过是的，这就是 Algol 和 Fortran 背后的那个约翰·巴克斯，他在1977年赢得了图灵奖。
And in his Turing Award lecture, he introduced a language called FP, which stood for function program, function program or function programming. And then that language evolved into FL, which stood for function level. And basically, I think it's widely not known that J, the second language that Ken Iverson worked on after creating APL and working on that for 30 years, wasn't just an evolution of APL. It was a combination of FL and APL.
在图灵奖演讲中，他引入了一种名为 FP 的语言，代表函数程序（function program）或函数编程（function programming）。然后该语言演变为 FL，代表函数级（function level）。基本上，我认为大家普遍不知道的是，肯·艾森伯格（Ken Iverson）在创建 APL 并研究了30年之后开发的第二种语言 J，不仅仅是 APL 的演变。它是 FL 和 APL 的结合体。
And in FL, John Backus had these things called combining forms, two of which were basically combinators. And Ken Iverson had a paper in 1989 called phrasal forms, which he actually references one of the combining forms called construction form that's introduced in the 78 paper. Anyways, so I've always had this view that like J was APL 2.0, but really it's like, you know, we did the quiz last week. J is APL plus FL, and no one knows about this language FL.
在 FL 中，约翰·巴克斯有被称为“组合形式”（combining forms）的东西，其中有两个基本上就是组合子。肯·艾森伯格在1989年发表过一篇名为《短语形式》（phrasal forms）的论文，其中他实际引用了78年论文中引入的一种名为“构造形式”（construction form）的组合形式。无论如何，我一直有这样一种观点，即 J 是 APL 2.0，但实际上，正如我们上周做的那样，J 是 APL 加上 FL，而没有人知道这个 FL 语言。
Thank you so much to Michael Garland, head of programming languages and models at NVIDIA. He's a senior director at NVIDIA Research. And yeah, programming languages is within here and system software are within his purview. Yeah, he was the individual that put the FL project paper on my radar. And he was like, you should go read this. I just looked it up and like, it's pretty obscure.
非常感谢英伟达的编程语言与模型负责人迈克尔·加兰（Michael Garland）。他是英伟达研究院的高级总监。是的，编程语言和系统软件就在他的管辖范围内。对，他就是把 FL 项目论文带到我的视野里的人。他说，你应该去读读这个。我刚查了一下，发现它相当冷门。
Like there's no, the syntax isn't even on the wikipedia page and i had to like click through to a few links to to find uh to find anything yeah so this is great i was actually so during functional comp the other day i was having a conversation with aaron and i basically told this mini story of how you know fp and like in that 78 paper by bacchus there's a whole paragraph basically thanking iverson because the name of the paper is can and some of you will have already read it or be familiar with it it's can we be liberated from von neumann languages and goes on to basically say that like algol and fortran were a big mistake imperative programming was a big mistake and that
就像根本没有……维基百科页面上甚至都没有它的语法，我不得不点击好几个链接才能找到……才能找到任何东西。所以这太棒了。实际上，在当天的 Functional Conf 期间，我和亚伦（Aaron）交谈，我基本上讲了这个小故事，你知道的，FP 和巴克斯在78年的那篇论文中，有一整段基本上是在感谢艾森伯格，因为这篇论文的名字是——你们中的一些人可能已经读过了或者很熟悉——《我们能从冯·诺依曼语言中解放出来吗》，接着它基本上说 Algol 和 Fortran 是个巨大的错误，命令式编程是个巨大的错误，并且
we should all head in the direction of functional programming languages which rely on these things called combining forms which is basically ways of composing programs to form other programs and combining forms is basically just another name for what would end up being called combinators and trains and the array languages and so he's he calls out to Iverson though and says that APL is one of the few languages that is actually going in the right direction, as opposed to like Algorand and Fortran. And so FP is highly influenced by APL, but Bacchus says that Iverson made a bunch of mistakes. And then, you know, fast forward, I guess, 12 years from 77, 78 to 1990. And then Iverson ends up holding a bunch of... Did you just say FP was influenced by FL?
我们都应该朝着函数式编程语言的方向前进，这些语言依赖于被称为“组合形式”的东西，这基本上是组合程序以形成其他程序的方法，“组合形式”基本上只是最终被称为组合子、数组语言中的“列车”（trains）的另一个名称。因此，他向艾森伯格致敬，并表示 APL 是少数几个真正朝着正确方向发展的语言之一，而不是像 Algol 和 Fortran 那样。因此，FP 受到了 APL 的极大影响，但巴克斯说艾森伯格犯了一堆错误。然后，快进，我猜，从77、78年到1990年，过了12年。然后艾森伯格最终举行了一堆……你刚才是不是说 FP 受到了 FL 的影响？
So FL is the basically successor language to FP. And they're very, very similar. It's just a few things were added that didn't exist in FP. And there was actually never an implementation of FP, but FL was actually implemented at IBM. Gotcha. And then the FL project report is basically like a 40-page paper
所以 FL 基本上是 FP 的后继语言。它们非常非常相似。只是增加了一些 FP 中不存在的东西。而且实际上从来没有过 FP 的实现，但 FL 确实在 IBM 被实现了。明白了。然后 FL 项目报告基本上就像是一篇40页的论文，
written by Alex Aiken, who's the programming language professor at Stanford. And some of you will be familiar with that name because he has, I think it's a Udacity or Coursera course, or maybe it's actually like a Stanford online course called Cool, where you implement a programming language called Cool, and it's like the compiler's course there. i i worked through part of that at one point that's the first time
由斯坦福大学编程语言教授亚历克斯·艾肯（Alex Aiken）撰写。你们中的一些人会对这个名字感到熟悉，因为他有一个，我想是 Udacity 或 Coursera 的课程，或者也许它实际上是一个名为 Cool 的斯坦福在线课程，你在其中实现一种名为 Cool 的编程语言，那是那里的编译器课程。我曾经一度学过其中的一部分，那是第一次
one of the legion people yeah he works part-time at nvidia he works one day a week for us um and um well i shouldn't say for us i by us i meant the greater company of nvidia um and uh and so yeah you know apl influenced fp then FP went on to become FL IBM implemented FL and then Professor Aiken and a couple others wrote this report on whether or not this sort of combinator point-free programming was a good idea and then Iverson so I would love it I don't know if it's our listeners or there's someone that I should go and be reaching out to. My guess is that at some point, I don't know where I have to go look at what Bacchus did with his career. But like, my guess is like Iverson and Bacchus were probably like colleagues or like, you know, at least acquaintances and met at conferences. And there
其中一个军团的人，对，他在英伟达兼职，他每周为我们工作一天，嗯，嗯……我可不该说为我们，我说的“我们”是指英伟达这个更大的公司。所以，是的，APL 影响了 FP，然后 FP 发展成为 FL，IBM 实现了 FL，接着艾肯教授和其他几个人写了这份报告，探讨这种组合子无点（point-free）编程是否是个好主意，然后艾森伯格……所以我也很乐意，我不知道我们的听众中是否有这样的人，或者有谁是我应该去联系的。我猜在某个时候，我不知道我得去查查巴克斯在他的职业生涯中做了什么。但是，我猜艾森伯格和巴克斯可能就像是同事，或者，你知道的，至少是熟人，并在会议上见过面，而且
was like a ton of idea sharing between the two. And anyways, so there's this just this, this huge sort of unknown history and like it only dawned on me a couple weeks ago in the last couple weeks that my favorite paper the 1989 phrasal forms by Iverson and I always say Iverson but it's actually he co-wrote it with Eugene McDonald as well and the name of that paper phrasal forms which was the initial name for what they would call combinators in the array languages, APL and, uh, and J, uh, trains is clearly inspired, uh, by the combining forms from Bacchus's 78 paper. It's combining forms, phrasal forms. And in J they, they had this
双方有大量的思想交流。无论如何，所以这里有这样一种巨大的、不为人知的历史，而且直到几周前，在过去几周里，我才突然意识到我最喜欢的论文——艾森伯格1989年的《短语形式》（我总是说是艾森伯格，但实际上他是和尤金·麦克唐纳（Eugene McDonald）共同撰写的），而那篇名为《短语形式》的论文（最初是他们后来在数组语言 APL 和 J 中称为组合子的词的初始名称）明显受到巴克斯78年论文中“组合形式”的启发。一个是“组合形式”，一个是“短语形式”。在 J 中，他们有这样一个
pattern of basically like taking things that already had decent names, but like renaming them in to the English grammar lexicon. So like functions were called verbs and arrays were called nouns and variables were called pronouns. And so they were like taking everything that already had a name and like renaming it so that it was like paralleled to grammar. You know what? Other programming language tried to have um syntactic elements that were that closely mirrored english uh i want to say pearl or raccoon think it think
模式，基本上就是把那些已经有了不错名字的东西，重新命名为符合英语语法词汇表的名字。比如函数被称为动词，数组被称为名词，变量被称为代词。所以他们把所有已经有名字的东西都拿来重新命名，让它们与语法相平行。你知道吗？还有什么编程语言曾试图拥有与英语高度相似的语法元素？我想说是 Perl 或 Raku。想想，想想
older think older because i know pearl when you want to print something it says like the keyword is like say cobalt cobalt that's right because cobalt so back in the day um you know cobalt was a contemporary of of fortran um and a few other languages but i'll say fortran because it was the the the one from that era that was most successful and still in use today um and fortran was a language designed for mathematics, for computer scientists. It was for solving numerical problems or I want to just broadly say science. Or maybe math is a better better way to put it so so Fortran was the language was a language for math and so it was natural for it to have a mathy syntax um but COBOL was a language for business um for for programming your business logic and for doing, I mean, I think if you look, if we were to take COBOL and put it into contemporary terms, it was a data analytics
年代更早的，想想更早的，因为我知道 Perl 在你想打印某些东西时，它的关键字就像是 say。COBOL。COBOL，没准儿真是。因为 COBOL，所以在过去，你知道的，COBOL 是 Fortran 的同代产品，还有其他一些语言，但我说 Fortran 是因为它是那个时代最成功并沿用至今的语言，Fortran 是一种为数学设计的语言，为了计算机科学家。它是为了解决数值问题，或者我想广义地说科学。或者也许数学是更好的表达方式，所以 Fortran 是用于数学的语言，因此它拥有数学化的语法是很自然的。但 COBOL 是用于商业的语言，用于编程你的商业业务逻辑，用于处理……我的意思是，如果你看的话，如果我们把 COBOL 放到当代语境中，它其实是一种数据分析
language. It was a language for, you know, writing, you know, software that was going to process some data that you have. And one of the goals and intentions in designing COBOL was to make it accessible to non-math people, to people who were just, you know, maybe not even engineers, but maybe just, you know, people who are on the business side of a company, to be able to write their business logic in COBOL. And so that's why COBOL essentially doesn't really have any operators. It's all just English. And if you look at the COBOL syntax, you'll see that it strives, in some some cases to a fault to just appear to be like english sentences and then in fact there are some cobalt programs that like you could read
语言。它是一种用于编写……处理你所拥有的某些数据的软件的语言。设计 COBOL 的目标和初衷之一，是让非数学背景的人也能轻松使用，让那些可能甚至不是工程师，而只是公司业务部门的人，也能够在 COBOL 中编写他们的业务逻辑。这就是为什么 COBOL 基本上没有任何运算符。它全部都是英文。如果你看一下 COBOL 的语法，你会发现它力求（有时甚至有些过头地）看起来就像英语句子，事实上，确实有一些 COBOL 程序，你可以把它
out to somebody and like sounds like you know that sounds like a sentence that like a regular human might utter yeah so well i think that so there's a difference too like there's a spectrum so cobalt and i've looked at some cobalt code and i've it used to be on my language list of languages that i wanted to learn but then after looking at it i no longer we just published a new cobalt standard come on yeah but like the verbosity of cobalt is is immense like a hello world program is like 40 lines long. Cause you have to, there's a bunch of stuff you have to set up for like every program. And they, they wanted to sort of like, they wanted it almost to be like executable, like sort of business. Like, so you could really like, like non-programmers could use it, which I think it probably succeeded in that goal. Uh, but for
读给某人听，听起来就像……那听起来就像是一个普通人类可能会说出的句子。是的。嗯，我认为，这里面也有不同，存在一个光谱。COBOL——我看过一些 COBOL 代码，它曾经在我的想学的语言列表中，但看完之后我不再……我们刚刚发布了一个新的 COBOL 标准！得了吧！是的，但是 COBOL 的冗长程度是极高的，一个 Hello World 程序有大约40行长。因为你必须……每个程序都有很多东西需要初始化。而且他们希望……他们几乎希望它就像是可执行的、类似于商业业务的东西。这样的话，非程序员真的可以像这样使用它，我想它可能在这个目标上成功了。但是对于
folks that are trying to do things like for someone who really likes APL, like myself, you're able to express yourself very tersely. COBOL is almost the opposite of that. So but the difference here is that COBOL actually reads like English, whereas J, you know, it's ASCII digraphs, it reads like hieroglyphics. But the terminology, like the names of things they chose to sort of be like English grammar. And in between those two sits Smalltalk, where Smalltalk was also designed sort of not to be aimed at business folks, but to also read very, very similarly to English. And so you read things left to right. And like, if you compose a bunch of unary messages, you'll have something like, you know, 10 times plus three print or something. Like that's a bad
那些试图做事情的人来说，比如像我这样非常喜欢 APL 的人，你能非常简洁地表达自己。COBOL 几乎与之相反。但这里的区别在于，COBOL 读起来确实像英语，而 J，你知道的，它是 ASCII 有向二元组，读起来就像象形文字。但它的术语，比如它们选择的事物的名称，旨在类似于英语语法。在这两者之间坐落着 Smalltalk，Smalltalk 的设计也不是为了针对商业人士，但它读起来也与英语非常非常相似。所以你是从左到右阅读的。如果你组合一堆一元消息，你就会得到类似于，比如，10 times plus three print 之类的东西。这是一个糟糕的
example that probably doesn't actually compile. But the goal of Alan Kay was to have a language that would be very, very easy to read without really not much knowledge of programming languages. And it was also one of the design goals of it was to be good for kids to learn. You know what, you know what, there another language that um i don't think was actually directly influenced by kobol but i think also has this property and and specifically a language that was designed originally i believe for beginners am i supposed to guess which one it is yeah you are um well i know logo was designed for beginners but i'm guessing that's not the language you're thinking of logo was like a scheme it had turtle graphics built into it. It was done by...
例子，它可能实际上无法编译。但艾伦·凯（Alan Kay）的目标是拥有一种无需太多编程语言知识就非常非常容易阅读的语言。它的设计目标之一也是适合小孩子们学习。你知道吗，你知道吗，还有另一种语言，嗯，我认为它其实并没有直接受到 COBOL 的影响，但我认为它也具备这种特性，特别是那种最初设计时我相信是给初学者用的语言……我是不是该猜猜是哪一个？是的，你来猜。嗯，我知道 Logo 是为初学者设计的，但我猜那不是你想的那种语言。Logo 就像是 Scheme，它内置了海龟图形。它是通过……
No, it's very much an imperative language. So what was the description? Inspired by COBOL, aimed at... I don't think directly inspired by COBOL, but I think its syntax is similar to COBOL in that it strives to be English words and sort of have a, um, uh, something close to a sentence to like an English sentence structure. Um, and it's something that I believe was originally intended to be for, um, uh, for non specialists for non-computer scientists and mathematicians. Yeah. Small talk's the language that comes to mind, but I can't think of a second one.
不，它非常像一种命令式语言。那么描述是什么？受 COBOL 启发，目标是……我认为没有直接受 COBOL 启发，但我认为它的语法类似于 COBOL，因为它力求成为英语单词，并且具有某种类似于英语句子的结构。而且，它是我相信最初打算用于非专业人士、非计算机科学家和数学家的一种语言。是的，Smalltalk 是浮现在脑海中的语言，但我实在想不出第二种。
Basic. Which I believe the B in basic stands for beginners. Really? Yeah. Hang on, let me... Yes, I am correct. Beginners All-Purpose Symbolic Instruction Code.
BASIC。我相信 BASIC 中的 B 代表的就是初学者（Beginners）。真的吗？是的。等一下，让我……是的，我是对的。初学者全能符号指令代码（Beginners All-Purpose Symbolic Instruction Code）。
Created at Dartmouth College in 1964. The creators wanted to enable students in non-scientific fields to use computers. At the time, nearly all computers required writing custom software, which only scientists and mathematicians tended to learn. I don't know whether it was influenced by cobalt um cobalt the original uh you know cobalt was the summer the designed in a very short period of time and i have my my best twitter thread um my pinned twitter thread is about the history of cobalt um in like the 1959 like the summer of 59 and then the report was published in 1960 and so basic came out in 64 it is possible that it was influenced by it but when i search for
1964年在达特茅斯学院创建。创造者希望让非科学领域的学生能够使用计算机。在当时，几乎所有的计算机都需要编写定制软件，而这通常只有科学家和数学家才会去学习。我不知道它是否受到了 COBOL 的影响……COBOL 原本的……你知道的，COBOL 是在很短的时间内设计的夏天，我最喜欢的 Twitter 线程——我置顶的 Twitter 线程就是关于 COBOL 的历史，在1959年左右，也就是59年的夏天，然后报告在1960年发表，而 BASIC 在64年问世，它有可能受到其影响，但当我在
cobalt on the basic wikipedia page i don't find anything but i think you know i started off programming in basic ti basic on my TI 89 calculator. And a lot of people in C++ say that they started off programming in basic. Are you one of them? I can't remember. Yeah, yeah. I think at one point it ended up coming up on an episode that, yeah, we both have a very similar, like, didn't start programming when we were six. And the first lines of code we wrote were on a TI basic, in TI basic on a TI 83 calculator in high school.
BASIC 的维基百科页面上搜索 COBOL 时，我什么也没找到。但我知道，我最早是从 BASIC 开始编程的——在我的 TI-89 计算器上使用 TI BASIC。许多 C++ 程序员都说他们是从 BASIC 开始编程的。你是其中之一吗？我不记得了。对，对。我想有一次在节目里聊到过，是的，我们俩都有非常相似的经历，没有在六岁时就开始编程，我们写的最初几代码是在高中时钛克（TI）计算器上的 TI BASIC 中完成的。
So, but then you get what I mean about the syntax, how it's very, it's essentially just English words. There aren't really operators. Yeah. Basic's a language, I mean, I coded a ton in Visual Basic application, which is the language that you've've want to if you want to program macros in Excel. And I also did back when I wanted to be a little finance quant, I wrote like three different versions of a technical analysis program that like would plot OHLC,
所以，不过你懂我说的语法，它是多么地……基本上就是英语单词。没有什么真正的操作符。是的。Basic 语言嘛，我的意思是，我在 Visual Basic Application 里写了大量的代码，如果你想在 Excel 中编写宏，这就是你要用到的语言。而且我也曾一度想成为一名小型金融量化人员，我写了三个不同版本的技术分析程序，可以绘制 OHLC，
open high, low close, sort of stock charts. And the first one that I implemented was in Visual Basic. And it was, it was so slow that like, I immediately switched to a different language, because like, it would start to draw all the little candlestick bars, which is it would take like 10 seconds to render, you know, the 200 different bars for each day of the last couple months um my my my initial musings with programming in my calculator were um not for so noble of intentions um i think the one of the first things i did was there was this game that i'd like downloaded onto my calculator um but my teacher had caught me playing it in class so i added a mode to the game where if you just pressed a key it dropped you into something that appeared to be like the regular
开盘价、最高价、最低价、收盘价，也就是那种股票图表。我实现的第一个版本是用 Visual Basic 写的。结果它太慢了，以至于我立刻换成了另一种语言，因为它开始绘制所有那些小K线图时，渲染过去几个月里每一天的200多根柱状图竟然需要大约10秒钟，你知道的……呃，我最初在计算器上编程的那些小心思，目的其实没那么高尚……我想我做的第一件事是，有一款游戏我下载到了计算器上，但被老师在课上抓包了，于是我给游戏加了一个模式：只要你按下一个键，它就会切到一个看起来像是常规的
calculator ti89 calculator prompt and like did basic math but if you did anything that that added up to like seven then it dropped you back into the game. And I thought that this was pretty, pretty damn clever. That is pretty, that's pretty good. That is also very me. Yeah. All right. Well, that was supposed to be, I mean, we're almost at the 25 minute mark and this was supposed to be an episode about our conference recap. Anyways, we'll talk more about this paper that I was going to submit and the history of APL, FP, FL, J on some other episode in the last five, 10 minutes here, because the next episode that you're going to hear next week that Bryce and I are going to record right after this is going to be a C++ interview and an actual question that I asked
TI-89 计算器提示符的界面，能做点基础数学运算，但如果你输入任何计算结果加起来等于7的东西，它就会把你带回游戏中。我觉得这个点子真是聪明透顶。确实挺聪明的，相当不错。这也非常符合我的作风。对啊。好了，本来这应该是……我的意思是，我们快到25分钟大关了，这本该是一期关于我们会议回顾的节目。总之，关于我本来要提交的那篇论文以及 APL、FP、FL、J 的历史，我们留到接下来的5到10分钟或者其他节目再聊，因为接下来这期你下周会听到的节目——也就是我和布莱斯马上要录制的——将是一场 C++ 面试，以及我前几天在面试
an intern or a potential intern in an interview the other day. And I had not, I've interviewed many co-op students or interns in a past career, but this was the first one at NVIDIA. And I actually didn't know if this question was too difficult. And so I thought, you know, there's a good way to figure this out. I'll ask Bryce and we will solve it live. And depending on how Bryce does, I think it's a great question and we're going to solve it family feud style. But stay tuned till next week. I mean, Bryce can stay tuned for like six minutes
一个实习生或潜在实习生时问过的一个实际问题。我以前在职业生涯中面试过很多合作项目的学生或实习生，但这在英伟达还是第一次。其实我当时并不确定这个问题是不是太难了，所以我想，有个好方法可以验证这一点：我来问问布莱斯，我们现场解答。根据布莱斯的表现，我觉得这是一个很棒的问题，我们将以《家庭问答》的形式来解答它。不过请大家拭目以待下周的节目。我是说，布莱斯大概只需要等个六分钟
and then I'll be asking him it. But the listener must wait until episode 72. In the last five, 10 minutes though, highlights, GDC 2022. I mean, this episode's now going to be called like Cobol, APL and FL. And they're just going to get a couple of highlights. And basic.
然后我就要问他了。但听众朋友们必须等到第 72 期节目。不过在最后这 5 到 10 分钟里，我们要讲讲亮点，2022年 GDC 大会。我的意思是，这期节目现在大概要被叫做《Cobol、APL 和 FL》了。大家只能听到几个亮点。还有 Basic。
Don't, don't. Oh, yeah. And basic. And basic. What do you want to say? Top three things that you should mention about GTC 2022. Talks people should go watch. Well, obviously my talk.
别，别。哦，对，还有 Basic。还有 Basic。你想说什么？关于 2022 年 GTC 大会，你认为最值得一提的三件事是什么？大家应该去听哪些演讲？显然是我的演讲。
Unless you've already seen my talk on C++ standard parallelism at another conference. In which case, this is more or less the same talk. There is some new stuff. There's some new cool applications and porting results. And we had a panel on the future of standard C++ with Daisy Hallman, Christian Trott, um, Eric Kneebler and Michael Garland. That was a really fun panel. I had a great time doing that. That was a good, a good group of people to, to put in a room and ask questions about C++. Um, yeah, I think those were the, those were the two big, uh, the two big things for me. Um, we also had a, uh, you know, sort of a user Q&A session for standard C++ and CUDA C++ and then another one
除非你已经在另一场会议上看过我关于 C++ 标准并行性的演讲了。那样的话，这场演讲大同小异。里面有一些新内容，包括一些很酷的新应用和移植结果。我们还举办了一个关于标准 C++ 未来的圆桌会议，嘉宾有黛西·霍尔曼（Daisy Hallman）、克里斯蒂安·特罗特（Christian Trott）、埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Kneebler）和迈克尔·加兰（Michael Garland）。那是一场非常有趣的圆桌讨论。我乐在其中。把这群人聚在一个房间里询问关于 C++ 的问题，体验太棒了。嗯，对，我觉得这就是那两个重头戏，对我来说是这两个大事件。嗯，我们当时还举办了……你知道的，针对标准 C++ 和 CUDA C++ 的用户问答环节，然后还有另一个
for all of our C++ core libraries. Those are always fun. What about you? What were your GTC highlights? I can echo what you just said. So I have a quote-unquote trip report that will be out by the time this airs.
针对我们所有 C++ 核心库的问答环节。那些总是很有趣。你呢？你的 GTC 亮点是什么？我完全附和你刚才说的话。所以，我有一份所谓的“出差报告”，等这期节目播出时应该已经发布了。
Oh man, I forgot about trip reports. You know, it's been two years since we traveled anywhere. I forgot about, you know, I used to write trip reports. Yeah, and it's kind of, I mean, the one thing about it being virtual is that it's easy to write it while you go through the week. And I think I watched like, I don't know, 15 or 20 talks slash connect with expert panels. So yeah, Bryce's talk. And so
天哪，我都快忘了出差报告这回事了。你知道的，我们已经两年没去任何地方旅行了。我都忘了……我以前经常写出差报告。对，而且某种程度上，虚拟会议的好处在于，你可以在过完整个星期的时候顺便把它写完。我想我大概看了15到20个演讲或者“与专家连线”的圆桌会议吧。所以，对，布莱斯的演讲。然后
I have a little legend to have like, good talk with a star next to it, you know, worth watching. There was a couple that had really bad audio. So I put a little emoji next to that. But yeah, your talk was great. I definitely agree that the panel that you had with Daisy Christian, Michael and Eric, that was, That was my favorite of the panel slash CWEs. Tim Costa's talk was great. Jeff Larkin's talk was great. I won't go into details what they're about. You can just go to the trip report, see the stars, go watch them if you're interested. But both, I mean, Jeff Larkin's talk, your talk, and Tim Costa's talk all sort of covered similar things, you know, the future C++, HBC Compute. There was also a fantastic talk from Jeff Hammond.
我做了一个小图例，比如：好的演讲旁边标一个星星，你知道的，值得一看。有些演讲的音频质量真的很差，所以我旁边加了个小表情符号。不过说真的，你的演讲太棒了。我绝对赞同你和黛西、克里斯蒂安、迈克尔还有埃里克的那场圆桌讨论，那是我的最爱。蒂姆·科斯塔（Tim Costa）的演讲很棒。杰夫·拉金（Jeff Larkin）的演讲也很棒。我就不详细展开它们的内容了。大家可以去看出差报告，找找那些星星图标，感兴趣的话就去看。不过这两人的演讲——杰夫·拉金的演讲、你的演讲、还有蒂姆·科斯塔的演讲——其实都涵盖了类似的内容，你知道的，未来的 C++、HPC 计算。此外，杰夫·哈蒙德（Jeff Hammond）也有一场精彩绝伦的演讲。
It's called The Gears of GPU Computing. And it gives a tiny brief history of like GPU programming, but then compares like OpenACC, OpenMP, Standard C++, CUDA C++, Standard Fortran, C++, like all these different, you know, CUPAI, the list goes on and on. And he takes three small, like, you know, one of them SACS-P, and then one of them's like, you know, matrix transpose, and then like one other operation. So three small sort of problems that, you know, ideally, a GPU is going to eat for breakfast. And then he basically like profiles them all against each other and has these nice little charts and it's it's like a super short like 20 25 minute talk uh but covers like a lot of ground olivia even when i tweeted it out was responding like shouldn't these all be the exact same and he's and jeff's end up replying
叫做《GPU 计算的齿轮》（The Gears of GPU Computing）。它简要回顾了 GPU 编程的历史，然后对比了 OpenACC、OpenMP、标准 C++, CUDA C++, 标准 Fortran、C++，以及所有这些不同的技术（你知道的，如 CUPAI，列表长得看不见头）。他挑选了三个小型问题——比如，其中一个是 SAXPY，然后一个是矩阵转置，还有一个是别的什么操作。也就是三个理想情况下 GPU 会轻松拿下的极小问题。然后他基本上把它们全部放在一起进行了性能分析，并做了一些非常棒的小图表。这是一个超级短的演讲，大概 20 到 25 分钟，但涵盖了非常多的领域。奥利维亚甚至在我发推特宣传时回复说：“这些不应该完全一样吗？”杰夫则回复说：
like uh didn't take long or didn't take long for you to forget about like unified memory or i don't know there's some thread i'll add it in the in the show notes but um all in all pretty exciting also i mean the keynote jensen's keynote's always uh pretty inspiring to watch the stuff like you know half the stuff that's going on at this company i'm not aware of and the keynote's always a good way to probably probably shouldn't say that in a public forum. Why? NVIDIA is huge. I'm supposed to know? I mean, you're a software politician. I've got my head down working on rapid stuff.
“没花多长时间你就把统一内存（Unified Memory）忘光了吧？”或者别的什么，我会在节目文稿里加上这个推特串的链接。不过总的来说，非常令人兴奋。还有，詹黄（黄仁勋）的主旨演讲总是非常鼓舞人心。公司里正在发生的很多事情——你知道的，有一半我其实都不知道。而且主旨演讲总是一个……我大概不该在公共场合这么说。为什么？英伟达体量这么大。我本该知道的？我的意思是，你是个软件政客。我正埋头苦干搞 Rapids 呢。
I mean, I don't know what's happening in, like, Omniverse land. Why would I know what's going on in Omniverse land? Well, actually, I have a coworker who's in the city who works. I don't know whether he works on Omniverse still. He may be doing a different thing he's uh he's told me many cool things about omniverse and it is very cool i mean it's super cool but like the only time i learn about it is when i watch jensen's i walk back i walk back i mean i walk back what i said i know it's our metaverse and it's going to be the best and yeah it's the future it's our omniverse like we were calling it that before people decided we're going to call it metaverse like we've been i think
我的意思是，我怎么知道 Omniverse 领域正发生着什么。我为什么要关心 Omniverse 领域的事？其实，我在城里有个同事就在那边工作。我不知道他现在是不是还在搞 Omniverse。他可能在做别的事情。他跟我讲过很多关于 Omniverse 的酷炫事情，它确实非常酷。我的意思是，超级酷。但问题是，我唯一能了解到它的机会就是看詹黄的演讲。我收回刚才的话。我收回我刚才说的话。我知道我们的 Omniverse，它将是最好的。是的，这就是未来，这就是我们的 Omniverse。我们在大家决定管它叫“元宇宙”之前就这么叫了。我们一直……我觉得
that's i think that's entirely false the metaverse doesn't that date back to like snow crash or something from like the 70s or 80s whatever my point is that we were whatever i mean, that's not a fact. And my point is that I'm right. Correct. Anyways, lots of great talks. Link it in the show notes. And very quickly, yeah, FunctionalConf. My two favorite talks. I might, well, I write a trip report. I don't really have time. But my two favorite talks, one was from Richard Feldman, who is pretty well known in the functional programming community, works at NoRedInk, which is a company that uses Elm as a functional programming language. And he has now recently started working on a new programming language called Rock, R-O-C.
我觉得这完全是胡扯。元宇宙这个词难道不是源于 70 或 80 年代的小说《雪崩》吗？不管怎样，我的重点是……不管怎样，这不是事实。我的重点是我才是对的。没错。总之，有很多精彩的演讲。链接会放在节目文稿中。接下来迅速聊聊 FunctionalConf。我最喜欢的两个演讲。我可能会……好吧，我会写一份出差报告，但我其实没时间。不过我最喜欢的两个演讲，一个是理查德·费尔德曼（Richard Feldman）带来的，他在函数式编程社区里相当知名，目前在 NoRedInk 工作（这是一家使用 Elm 作为函数式编程语言的公司）。他最近开始着手开发一门名为 Roc（R-O-C）的新编程语言。
I think that actually might be the first time we've mentioned Rock on this podcast. And he's had a bunch of really, really popular, successful talks in the past, like why isn't functional programming the norm, things like that. Anyways, his talk, he gave a keynote. The three keynotes, the first was by Richard Fellman, and it was entitled The Essence of Functional Programming. The second was by Bartosz Maluski, Mr. Category Theory,
我想这可能是在本播客中第一次提到 Roc。他过去做过一堆非常非常受欢迎、非常成功的演讲，比如“为什么函数式编程不是常态”之类的话题。总之，他的演讲是一场主旨演讲。三场主旨演讲中，第一场由理查德·费尔德曼主讲，题为《函数式编程的本质》。第二场由巴托斯·马留斯基（Bartosz Miluszkie，也就是类别论先生）主讲，
and it was on optics and lenses, which is sort of, if you're familiar with Haskell, you've probably heard of that. And then the closing it was on optics and lenses, which is sort of if you're familiar with Haskell, you've probably heard of that. And then the closing keynote was by Bruce Tate, the author of seven languages in seven weeks. And he actually he gave a very entertaining talk wasn't super technical, but like the first half of the talk, he gave the talk from a boat. He was in he was in his boat, and he was doing something Have you heard? And we got to wrap this episode up because we got to get to episode 72. Have you heard of? Now we clearly have life goals, which is to record a podcast episode.
主题是“光学与透镜”（optics and lenses），如果你熟悉 Haskell 语言，你大概听说过这个。然后闭幕主题演讲由布鲁斯·泰特（Bruce Tate）主讲，他是《七周七语言》的作者。他实际上带来了一场非常有趣的演讲，技术性不算特别强，但演讲的前半部分，他居然是在一条船上发表的！他在船上，然后他正在做……你听说过吗？我们得结束这期节目了，因为我们还得去录第 72 期。你听说过吗？现在我们显然有了新的人生目标，那就是在录制播客节目的同时，
Give a keynote from a boat. Have you heard of the Great American Tour or something like that? Have you ever heard of this? I probably just got it wrong. You're Googling it right now, right? I was shaking my head. I was not googling it. Then I realized this is a podcast. So shaking my head does not not really help the listener. Yeah, I mean, maybe it's the Great American Loop. But basically, it's this it's this loop you can take by boat that I mean, you can start anywhere on the loop, but it goes actually by Lake Ontario and Toronto through the Great Lakes,
在一艘船上发表主旨演讲。你听说过“大美国环游”（Great American Tour）之类的东西吗？你听说过这个吗？我可能刚刚说错了。你现在正在用谷歌搜索对吧？我刚才在摇头。我没在搜。然后我意识到这是个播客。所以摇头对听众来说没什么卵用。好吧，我的意思是，也许叫“大美国环路”（Great American Loop）。但基本上，这是一条你可以乘船完成的环线。我的意思是，你可以在环路的任何地方出发，但它实际上会经过安大略湖、多伦多、五大湖，
down through like Chicago, Illinois, all the way down to the bottom of America, out through some state down there around the, you know, Florida Gulf. Which state, Connor? I don't know. I don't think it's Texas. What's next to Texas? Louisiana? Connor, this is down the mississippi i presume which which state
然后穿过芝加哥、伊利诺伊州，一路向南直抵美利坚的最南端，从那里的某个州穿出去，绕过佛罗里达湾。那是哪个州，康纳？我不知道。我觉得不是得克萨斯州。挨着得克萨斯州的是什么？路易斯安那州？康纳，这条河顺流而下应该是密西西比河，我猜。那么，密西西比河最终在哪个州
famously does the mississippi terminate at i don't know uh i mean i'm gonna say i don't know georgia louisiana i'm not i'm not american i hope you saved that that material from, like, when we recorded, like, two or three weeks ago, where you demonstrated, like, enormous ineptitude at knowledge of U.S. history. It was like, there was, like, I asked Connor, like, did the War of 1812 happen before the Civil War? And it was, like, a struggle to get him to the correct answer. Man, was that right? It looks like it is Louisiana. What do you give me such a hard time for, man? The only reason I'm doubting myself is because you're like laughing at me like, man, you got to know this.
汇入大海？我不知道……呃，我要说是佐治亚州、路易斯安那州？我不是美国人。我希望你把这段素材保存下来——就像我们两三周前录制的那样，当时你展现出了对美国历史知识的极其无知。当时我问康纳：“1812年战争发生在南北战争之前吗？”结果他费了好大劲才得出正确答案。天哪，那次猜对了吗？看起来好像是路易斯安那州。你为什么总是这么难为我呢？我之所以怀疑自己，是因为你一直在嘲笑我，好像在说：“老兄，你连这都不知道。”
Well, like also, I lived in Louisiana for, you know, four years. So, yeah, I've been to New Orleans twice. Lived in Louisiana for, you know, four years. Yeah, I've been to New Orleans twice. Look, I even say it right. New Orleans. That's the correct way to say it. Anyways, the point is, Bruce Tate gives a keynote about this huge, he's going to be doing this tour until October. And it's March right now. And it goes all the way around Florida, up the coast, through i don't know some river in new york or connecticut
好吧，而且我还曾在路易斯安那州住过四年呢。所以，是的，我去过新奥尔良两次。在路易斯安那州住过四年，对，去过新奥尔良两次。你看，我甚至读对了。New Orleans。这才是正确的发音。总之，重点是，布鲁斯·泰特发表了一场关于这次庞大旅行的主旨演讲，他将一直进行这次环游直到十月份。而现在才三月份。这条路线将绕过整个佛罗里达，沿着海岸北上，穿过纽约或康涅狄格州的某条河流
or something anyways it's crazy first of all didn't know you could do that second of all didn't know it was a thing third of all given a keynote from that boat trip that's a pretty it's a pretty cool thing to do um so i mean most of the talk was about the boat trip and it was it was to do with loops because it's a loop that he's on right now and like the q a though and i felt like i was at a boat conference not at a it was just this one guy asking questions about uh you know the the garmin system that he had set up and like you know how he you know how he dealt with this and that and alligators and stuff anyways entertaining talk um not super technical though but anything you want to say to close this episode out?
或者别的什么地方。总之，太疯狂了。首先，我不知道还能这么玩；其次，我不知道有这回事；第三，居然能在那次船旅中发表主旨演讲，这绝对是一件非常酷的事情。所以，我的意思是，演讲的大部分内容都跟这次划船之旅有关，而且还和“循环”（loops）有关，因为他现在正处于一个环路（loop）上。不过问答环节嘛，我觉得自己仿佛置身于一个划船大会，而不是一个技术会议。台下只有一个家伙在不停地提问，问关于他搭建的 Garmin 系统啊，诸如此类的事，还有他是怎么对付这个、那个以及短吻鳄什么的。总之，这是一场有趣的演讲，虽然技术性不强，但对于结束这期节目你还有什么想说的吗？
I'm just thinking about what type of boat you and I need to get, Connor. Like, this is definitely happening. That's actually, that's, wow, I didn't even think about that. Like, we have a proverbial boat. I mean, you have a proverbial boat. Yes, I have a proverbial boat. But how much better would it be if i had an actual boat i mean this is in our future i i now see us yeah we've got the balkans 2023 tour look
我只是在想你和我需要买什么类型的船，康纳。这绝对得安排上。实际上，那是……哇，我之前都没想过这个。我们有一艘“所谓的”船。我是说，你有一艘“所谓的”船。对，我有一艘“所谓的”船。但如果我有一艘真正的船，那该有多好？我的意思是，这在我们的未来。我现在能想象到我们了。是的，我们有 2023 年巴尔干半岛之旅，瞧瞧
i am a white guy from connecticut so there's like some law that by the time i'm 40 i have to own a boat everybody in other case every like male in connecticut owns a boat i will never own a boat i mean i've never even owned a car um i don't like like it gives me anxiety just thinking about having a boat and like how much work that would be i would rather just like airbnb a boat i'm sure there's like an airbnb service yeah yeah i mean there's probably there's probably i mean there's an app for like, like, you know, there's,
我是一个来自康涅狄格州的白人男子，所以好像有什么法律规定，我到 40 岁时就必须拥有一艘船。在康涅狄格州，每个人……每个男性都拥有一艘船。我永远不会买船。我的意思是，我甚至从来没买过车。光是想到要拥有一艘船，以及那得需要多少维护工作，我就感到焦虑。我宁愿在爱彼迎（Airbnb）上租一艘船。我确信一定有那种爱彼迎租船服务。对，对，我的意思是，可能确实有。我的意思是，有一个类似于汽车版爱彼迎的应用程序，
there's the air, the equivalent of Airbnb for cars. It's, there's an app called Turo, which I've used. Um, I'm sure there's some equivalent for boats or maybe Turo does boats too. If we do cars.
有一个叫 Turo 的应用，我用过。嗯，我确信船只也有类似的平台，或者说 Turo 也有租船服务。如果我们能租车的话。
Anyways, well, stay tuned. Listener Airbnb for boats. We'll be boating. We'll be recording an episode from a boat sometime in the next 10 years, stay tuned, listener. I'm googling Airbnb for boats. We'll be boating. We'll be recording an episode from a boat sometime in the next 10 years, in the next decade. That's an ADSP, the podcast promise.
总之，请拭目以待，听众朋友们。爱彼迎租船。我们会去划船。在未来 10 年内的某个时间，我们将在船上录制一期播客，敬请期待，听众朋友们。我正在用谷歌搜索“租船版爱彼迎”。我们会去划船的。在未来十年内，我们会在船上录制一期节目。这就是 ADSP 播客的承诺。
Yes, it is. All right. Episode 71 is over. Are you ready? No, I am not ready. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，没错。好了，第 71 期节目结束了。你准备好了吗？不，我还没准备好。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。